E allora la situazione è questa oggi sono andata a fare la spesa. ho fatto una spesa un po' particolare.
si chiama abete di Manfredonia,come  si chiama
Comunque è un abete e
alle grazie
ecco questo è il backstage chiaramente è un road movie
Diretto da tim burton
Adesso c'è lo scambio di pasqua
Diciamo che è un po storto,diciamo che è un po come la torre di pisa pende da un lato scopriremo sulla casa da cuore
Ma deve farlo
Una strada tra martina presenti alla rampa poteva essere quella lasciata
Molto semplice ma proseguiamo il nostro viaggio
Nel mondo, del natale allora questa beta e una
Verde
Verde silver perché anche delle sfumature si deve riscoprire the passion
Di realtà e non però un po andremo a twitter harlow perché no per niente tutti a casa mia avete visto
Come trasportato l'albero è stata una cosa molto divertente molto particolare e adesso
andiamo al sodo quindi fare l'albero ecco faceva notare che io ho vinto spesso premi
In apertura di scatole perché come vedete. Ho una grazia una dote particolare
nel proprio
Sventrare le scatole proprio in generale lo sono a numero di prede
biscotti tante altre cose
Ma torniamo a noi forbici a punta arrotondata come direbbe tonio cartonio della previsione
Lauzi non era da riprendere in mano ormai l'impatto è niente. Eh no
Vabbè comunque restare in casa ragazzi in amicizia proprio come se fosse. I nemici licata
diventarmi non fare l'albero allora sarà divertente ripulire tutto lo sporco che sta saldando anche in faccia
Bene allora un pezzo che ho fatto
Ma il cammino si apre
E bellissimo forse sapete che forse il primo albero vero
Che ho problemi a vita allora questo
Alzarlo ma pesanti da di centa e non so se farò
Ok
L'albero, c'è
Ecco diciamo che me lo aspettavo un po più dritto diciamo che è un po come la torre di pisa
vende a
Destra
Lo portiamo dietro
scarichiamo sul mio letto
Ridatemi I soldi
basteranno questi balocchi perché insomma, non
Facendo numeri di un po di anni non. Sapevo quantificare le modalità di calcio
Non verbo ma soprattutto una volta a roma tra l'altro pd io ho capito all'occhio prima dell'albero quindi siccome sono per natura, non
troppo grosse che mi basteranno alla fine l'altro abbastanza grosso
Vediamo se non sarà troppo vuoto a premessa
I colori dell'albero allora di solito mi piace molto rosso e oro
del k qualche attrito l'oro è un peccato
Che la mia cucina e sono a riprendere perché tutta disordinata venivo faremo dopo manata al volto per vita e di colori comunque
argento grigio quindi bianco quindi mi sono sentita come
costretta per diciamo
bene comune
A prendergli argento bianco quindi non. Lo sarà bianco argentato che uno guastando lavoro nero bianco argento
oro nero
giorgio via progetto marina nuova si nuovo singolo in uscita a natale non è vero però però però questi colori
Da shin food snom one works office. Il nodo sulla
Mappa
iniziamo con il primo balocco a caso
Allora da dove si inizia io tipo un po inesperta in questo momento un po inesperta in questo momento brava la prima pallina di pesca
Regola sono, levare le reti degli alberi dal peso per sempre nella
Chiaramente nella classica indifferenziata
Citata
Ma guarda avrà oltre classici volo chi
crede litteram venisse
parcheggi di
questi cuori che tra super ciro
simonetti
impressioni messi
Mi trasformo un po in quel personaggio come ho capito
e nei
buchi
Allora dicevo abbiamo quasi finito le palline
I balocchi e abbiamo aggiunto anche queste pigne che io non pensavo di mettere nell'albero perché sono appunto un po
Dorate però alla fine. Nel complesso ci stanno bene dalla pole il tocco shine
Che non ci sta per niente male quindi direi che sono approvate
Mancano dunque dopo di che facciamo mettere I cuoricini
Le cucine e le vicine
Allora se magari poi il
Caso del profilo e lo possono riempire ancora un po però non sapendo appunto che albero a comprare non. Ho voluto esagerare però
Poi magari un rito allora arrivato il momento clou ci
diciamo che
abbiamo riempito abbastanza no
Adesso manca le luminarie che prima era in camera mia perché come sapete io ho una passione per le lucine quindi, non
È che ne tiro fuori solo a natale diciamo che sono evergreen per quanto mi riguarda
I nonni sono dappertutto
adesso favino
persone compreso un albero finto
Ma deve arrivare il momento di pannello bundles come
Allora ragazzi vi. Devo aggiornare perché dall'ultima crisi sono passati due giorni e in questi due giorni
Ho sconvolto tutto perché l'angolo non è più. Dove era prima ho cambiato posizione
dell'albero per una questione di voci prese ci precede e
Soprattutto suonata a comprare dei nuovi balocchi perché mi sembrava un po bonino fu preso queste qua trasparenti con. I disegni bianchi
Poi, ho preso le stelline un po glitterato è così che sono super super carine e poi. I fiocchi di neve argentati per atelier
belli
E poi delle piccole dei piccoli balocchi insomma molto simili a quelli che avevo già grandi però sono più piccoli sono
perfetti per riempire insomma di buchi
Che dovevano essere riempiti
Un'altra cosa che mancava oltre ai balocchi insomma per riempire l'albero era la punta perché a me non piacciono tanto
Le punte quelle classiche lunga eccetera eccetera il momento di solito sull'hardware volevo qualcosa di più originale
Quindi appunto in questo negozio di pochi trovato questo è un altro che aveva proprio questi colori bianco argento e ha detto ma perché la
facciamo un bel fiocco come punta dell'albero e quindi ecco a voi
La mia punta dell'albero celi un fiocco che io l'adoro
Mi piace molto come sta con. La trovo molto molto chic
mon.do
magica può vedere l'albero
e luce fu
Nel mentre ha pure inizia la verità dei ragazzi top
spero tanto che vi piaccia mio albero insomma questione e mezzo fa luci spente e fatemi sapere come
mi piace e
soprattutto
tenetevi pronti perché arriveranno tantissimi nuovi prof